la función que está definida sobre los
números reales en esta tabla se dan
varios valores de g cuál es una
estimación razonable para el límite
cuando extiende a 5 deje de x
hasta que pausa el vídeo observa esta
tabla
ips puedes encontrar este límite en esta
tabla podrás encontrar valores de x
menores a 5 que se aproximan a 5 y
también valores más grandes que 5 que se
aproximan a 5 además nos dice cuánto
vale la función en 5 y con esto puedes
preguntarte cuál es una estimación
razonable para el límite cuando
extiendes incoop dgt x
ok vamos a trabajar los puntos primero
pensemos a qué valor se aproxima g
cuando x se aproxima a 5 desde valores
más pequeños que 5 vamos a ver tengo que
cuando x vale 4 de x vale 3.37 cuando ex
vale 4.9 gedex vale 3.5 4.99 3.66 4.99 9
es decir un milésimo antes que 5 tengo
el valor de 3.68 estoy muy muy muy cerca
5 y luego en 5 tomamos otro valor
incluso parece que estamos dando un
salto hasta 6.37 ojo sólo estoy
infiriendo esta idea quiero aclarar que
estos son sólo unos puntos muestran que
nos dan de nuestra función que no
sabemos bien cómo es la función y ahora
si nos aproximamos a 5 por valores más
grandes que 5 observa tengo que 6 me da
3.97 5.1 3.84 5.0 13.7 5.001
y 3.68 es decir una milésima antes de
cinco y una milésima después de cinco
tomamos el valor de 3.68 y después en
cinco tomamos el valor de 6.37 así que
una estimación razonable parece ser que
al aproximarnos a 5 tomamos el valor de
3.68 cuando nos acercamos por valores
menores que 5 nos acercamos al valor de
3.68 y pasa lo mismo con valores mayores
que 5 sin importar que el valor de 5 sea
6.37 entonces el límite o al menos una
estimación razonable para el límite va a
ser 3.68 y déjame seleccionar esa
respuesta y justo el inciso de es el
mayor de extractor que te da el problema
porque si simplemente sustituye el valor
de 5 vas a obtener el valor de g de 5
que es como dice la tabla 6.37 pero
recuerda el límite no forzosamente debe
de valer lo que vale la función en s
así que qué te parece si dibujo unos
ejes por aquí para que entiendas de una
manera gráfica lo que estoy diciendo si
por aquí tengo al 5 el valor que toma mi
función en ese punto es de 6.37 así que
vamos a ponerlo y ahora si nos
aproximamos al 5 déjame poner por aquí
al 4 y por acá voy a poner al 6
obviamente esto no está escala y ahora
así por aquí tengo el valor de 3.68 y
pienso que nos podemos acercar a él por
valores menores que 5 bueno me voy
acercando a ese valor y después por
valores mayores que 5 pasa lo mismo así
que la gráfica se ve más o menos así o
podemos inferir que se ve más o menos
así donde nos estamos aproximando a 3.68
por la izquierda y por la derecha pero
justo en 5000 valores de 6.37
no podemos asegurar que así se vea la
gráfica ya que solo tenemos algunos
puntos de referencia pero creo que esta
es una buena diferencia de lo que estaba
pasando y por lo tanto puedes ver que el
límite se está aproximando 3.68 aunque
la función tome un valor distinto en
este punto muy bien este es el final del
vídeo así que nos vemos en el siguiente